dans les familles musulmanes il y a une
une hiérarchie qui est très imposée dans
les quartiers il y a une hiérarchie très
imposé c'est pour ça que les filles
hésitent maintenant à sortir sans un
voile sur la tête c'est pour ça que il y
a constamment les pressions qui sont
fait sur eux c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
une
une une marche où tous les deux nous
marcherions main dans la main serait
très compliqué à mettre en place pour
mais non non parce que parce que ça
irait à l'encontre de la tactique des
islamistes qui souhaitent justement je
le répète diviser les communautés le don
pas al mais les G les gens qui vont à
ces manifestations c'est pas des
islamistes les gens qui c'est faut pas
mettre tout le monde dans le même sac et
les oui il y a des femmes c'est vrai
qu'il y a des femmes qui sont forcesé à
mettre le voile mais il y a des femmes
qui sont très heureuses ma mère porte le
voile je peux vous dire qu'il y a
personne qui la force à rien faire c'est
plus elle qui force mon père à enlever
ses chaussures quand elle rentre à la
maison
non mais après le bat on a tous marché
pourquoi là on n pas capable de tous
marcher ensemble mais moi c'est c'est
moi c'est le je suis peut-être naïf
comme vous mais c'est le rêve que j'ai
la pai et qu'on soit tous apisé vous
avez vu que les manifestations en
soutien au peuple palestinien sont
interdites est-ce vous comprenez cette
décision Gill moi pas du tout je trouve
que c'est une erreur grave alors
attention dès qu'il y a un cri pro has
dès qu'il y a une banderôle là apologie
du terrorisme on sanctionne on s ve mais
que les gens qui soutiennent le peuple
palestin tout en condamnant bien sûr les
monstrueux attentats en Israël que ces
gens ne puissent pas dire leur soutien
au peuple au civil de Gaza je trouve que
c'est une erreur parce que comment
vont-ils pouvoir manifester ce soutien
s'ils ne peuvent pas le faire dans une
manifestation encadré sécurisé avec des
forces de l'ordre autour moi je crains
qu'il le fasse ailleurs où ce sera pas
encadré donc pour moi je comprends le
gouvernement mais pour moi c'est une
mauvaise décision est-ce que vous
comprenez cette décision Daniel ah oui
tout à fait moi j'été vraiment choqué
hier parce qu'on a quand même entendu à
4 jours non non mais tu comprends cette
décision toi la décision de l'avoir oui
interdit bien sûr parce que j'ai été
choqué par ces images c'est incroyable
d'entendre tu comprends la décision
d'interdire les les manifestations bien
sûr bien sûr et j'étais complètement
choqué je voudrais le dire parce que en
Israël assassin à 4 jours de
décapitation de bébés en Israël et et et
laisser ces gens ces gens-là parce qu'on
dit les réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux il y a de la merde tout le temps
il y a des gens qui sont cachés qui
disent de la merde toutes là ce sont des
gens à visage découvert on est en plein
Paris il 4 jours il y a eu mais des
abominations vous les avez et je je je
trouve que c'est bien de de les de les
raconter parce que on s'en rend pas
compte c'est des mots donc c'est très
bien ce que vous avez fait shuraki et on
a entendu sioniste terroriste Israël
assassin on est dans des revendications
c'est moi ça j'ai été choqué j'ai eu
honte j'ai eu honte de mon pays il y a
pas que ça il y a pas que ça pas que ça
il y en a qui viennent dans la paix et
il y en a qui prent le même discours que
moi qui veulent juste marché et qui qui
end à 4 jours de ce qui s'est passé je
suis désolé a partout il a sur plate qu'
a dans la rue il y en a partout des
imbéciles dans ce genre de moment tu dis
ça pour moi je pensis mais je il y en a
de partout mais interdire bah
malheureusement c'est pousser les gens à
l'affront c'est pousser les gens à la
sens mais si on a un raisonement comme
ça on interdit plus rien c'est interdiss
quelqu'un qui crie Mor au Juif bien
évidemment bien évidemment qu'on
interdit quelqu'un et qu'on punisse
quelqu'un qui dit mort au Juif
évidemment ça coûte de sources le le feu
ça ça brûle et l'eau ça mouille mais je
veux dire il un moment où faut les
laisser aussi s'exprimer c'est pas un
gros mot que stir et puis on a un
gouvernement on a un gouvernement qui
est quand même logiquement censé pouvoir
encadrer des manifestations pour qu'ell
se passe dans de bonnes conditions pour
que les messages passés soient des
messages de paix si un moment ce
gouvernement là n'est pas capable de
gérer ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi donc
vous vous comprenez pas la décision moi
moi je je je la comprends vu la
tristesse de notre gouvernement et son
niveau par contre dans d'autres
circonstances je pense que ça aurait été
une bonne chose parce que ça peut être
aussi un message de paix Guillaume toi
tu es pas d'accord moi je la comprends
pas parce que je trouve qu'il y a des
raccourcis et des amalgames qui sont
faits qui sont dangereux en fait on
sous-entend que cette manifestation en
fait Faur des civils palestiniens on
fait passer ces milliers de personnes
pour des personnes qui cautionnent le
terrorisme qui encouragent le terrorisme
et qui sont d'accord avec ce qui sont
passés non c'est trop facile voilà il
faut expliquer les choses ces
personnages je ne peux pas croire que
les milliers de personnes qui sont là
sont des terroristes ou encouragent ce
qui s'est passé et malheureusement
aujourd'hui bah on tombe dans des
raccourcis on tombe dans des amalgames
et on veut opposer les gens et en
interdisant ce genre de chos on va
encore diviser on va encore créer des
tensions et c'est pas la suis désolé on
est tombé hier sur Karim Z qui disait
oui mais là pour moi c'est oui mais
c'est on défend la cause palestinienne
qu quelque part c'est justifié ce qui
s'est passé il y a qu jours ah ben
excusez-moi est-ce que vous comprenez la
décision du gouvernement je la comprends
moi je doute pas de la sincérité
effectivement de certains qui veulent
manifester pour le peuple palestinien et
qui qui ne qu' faut évidemment la
dissociation entre le peuple palestinien
et le Hamas mais la question qui se pose
c'est qui organise ces manifestations
parmi les organisateurs il y a action
Palestine je suis allée sur le site moi
d'action Palestine parce que ça
m'intéresse de savoir sur le site il y a
marqué que c'était une organisation pour
saluer l'exploit de la résistance
palestinienne ce qui s'est passé hier
avec le ce qui s'est passé avec le Hamas
c'est la résistance palestinienne tuer
des femmes et des enfants c'est la
résistance palestinienne c'est ça aider
la cause palestinienne donc moi s'il y a
une manifestation où on arrive mais je
mais je je crains qu'onarrive pas à le
faire on arrive à dissocier
effectivement et et une vraie
manifestation en disant c'est un soutien
avec le peuple sauf que là ça va être
évidemment infiltré par moi ce ce qu'on
aimerait voir c'est des manifestations à
soutien en Israël où il y est justement
des personnes qui fassent les deux
personnes qui so
Mar israë exactement et c'est vrai que
ce ce qui est dramatique aujourd'hui
c'est que a
voilà je pe poser une question à RAM
Ramous est-ce que vous vous pensez au
voilà au fond de vous et tout ça est-ce
que vous pensez vraiment que en France
les musulmans sont d'accord pour avoir
deux états au fond vraiment un État
palestinien un état israélien alors ce
moment non mais vous non mais vous bien
sûr évidemment c'est ce que vous dit
dans votre vidé pourquoi cette marche
n'est pas-moi si moi je marche dans une
manifestation alors si je vais comme
celle que de Sarah Alimi si j'entends
Mor aux Arabes je gifle la personne qui
dit ça si je vais dans une manifestation
palestinienne j'entends mort au Juif je
le gifle ben comme c'est l'immense
majorité cette marche est donc possible
bien sûr que c'est possible non mais on
sait très bien que c'est toujours la
minorité qui sont les fauteurs de
trouble aussi don pas raison à la
barbarie au
teror les mecs qui tiennent ses propos
ils savent même pas mettre la Palestine
et l'Israël sur la carte mec sont
totalementignorant pas sûr que les gens
de la Franceis les mettre aussi hein je
vous le dis je je pense vraiment que là
ils ont dû vérifier parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois que je leur dis donc ils
ont dire au cas où on vous interroge on
va les voir mais je pense qu'il a une
semaine il savait pas vous mooun vous
êtes vous êtes vous comprenez pas la
décision non je comprends pas bah en
fait je rejoins un petit peu Gilles et
et Guillaume c'est en fait je je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui il y a un souci
de gestion de de ce conflit maintenant
aujourd'hui enfin je pense qu'une une
marche pour la paix c'est ce serait
vraiment la sol
it
Ann je ve dire la Palestine autant
queisraël subisse des violences depuis
des années aujourd'hui si les
proalestiniens ont envie de faire une
manifestation manifestation pour faire
entendre leur voix je comprends en
revanche action
palestinez Mor au
Juif évidment les gens qui disent ça
évidemment que ils ont pas leoit de de
manifester maintenant je trouve que
c'est contreproductif que d'interdire
parce que du coup les gens vont vouloir
créer des manifestations en dehors de
l'autorisation et de quelque chose de de
de structurer et donc c'est là qu'il va
y avoir des violences et on va donner
raison en fait à ces violences Michel
mer ouais moi je crois que c'est là on
est des beau discours mais c'est de
l'angélisme total parce que pour moi les
manifestations c'est pas des
manifestation de paix c'est des
manifestations de colère c'est une sorte
de rapport de force qu'on va instaurer
dans la rue et je crois que
malheureusement on est arrivé à un tel
stade c'est que maintenant on est arrivé
dans une sorte de choisis ton camp et
d'affrontement maintenant c'est on est
plus du tout dans la recherche d'un il
faudrait qu'il a un gagnant quelque part
je me dis ça maintenant les deux camps
s'affrontent jusqu'à ce qu'il y a un
gagnant mais je le sens comme ça
j'écoute la plart beaucoup de person
parend personne les réseauaux j'entend
des discours de Pai ex quand tu écoutes
les gens qui sont engagés
émotionnellement dans un camp ou dans un
autre ils sont plus dans la recherche
d'un compromis dans la recherche d'une
paix l'action qui a été menée en
Palestine par le Rama c'était pas pour
essayer de se mettre autour de la table
cétait pour engager
une guerre totale entre tous les pays
qui composent
pr tu fais pas ça quand tu veux la paix
tu fais pas ça donc là maintenant tout
le monde a bien compris le message dans
cas ou dans un autre que maintenant on
en est plus discussion maintenant il va
falloir que ça F et il faut un gagnant
moi je
ça je comprends la décision de Monsieur
Darmanin et je la trouve totalement
responsable parce que lui il est à la
tête d'un ministère qui a les les
renseignements
et qui connaît donc la vraie ligne de
fracture qu'il y a dans ce pays il a les
vrais remontées sur les actes
d'antisémitisme il a les vrais remontées
sur les niveau de tension qui peut y
avoir ici ou là son rôle c'est tout
simplement de protéger la population et
pas de faire en sorte que les les les
communautés se montent les unes contre
contre les autres et je rejoins tout à
fait ce que vient de dire Jean-Michel
c'est que malheureusement ce constat là
on peut pas faire d'angélisme
aujourd'hui le constat c'est que
malheureusement on n'est pas en mesure
de faire cette fameuse marche qu'on
aimerait tous voir où tout le monde
serait ensemble derrière la paix ou
derrière une volonté de deux états et il
faut pas dire n'importe quoi je lisais
également sur les réseaux que la France
fait rien contre il y a un homme
politique fameux qui dit aujourd'hui que
la France ne fait rien pour une solution
à deux états il y a eu c'est qui c'est
qui Villepin Dominique de vpin non non
c'est c'est c'est la France insoumise
qui qui qui en remis une louche mais non
je veux dire il y a eu il y a eu il y a
eu beaucoup d'actions européennes ou
françaises pour essayer de faire en
sorte que il il y a une solution à à
deux États mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que ce que votre message il est
formidable ce soir et votre message il
est extrêmement puissant à l'un et à
l'autre et à mon avis c'est bien plus
porteur que malheureusement des
rassemblements qui se termineraient mal
où les gens se mettraient dessus et où
en plus on entend des à Mor Israël ou à
Mor je ne sais quoi et bon voilà c je
pense que malheureusement il y a pas de
manifestation aujourd'hui qui soit
proalestinien les manifestations qui se
mettent en place sont des manifestations
TR hamass on ne peut pas manifester pour
un groupe terroriste est-ce que vous
auriez accepté en
1900 38 39 à Paris ou à Berlin qui est
des manifestations pronazis
profascisme on ne peut pas accepter ça
et le Hamas est un groupe terroriste
d'une violence qu'on n pas connu depuis
très longtemps depuis daesh donc on ne
peut pas les accepter on ne peut pas les
interdire si un jour les choses
s'appellent
si un dialogue s'installe soyons voyons
l'utopie jusqu'au bout si un dialogue
s'installe entre Israël et et les pays
alentour les pays dont la Palestine
évidemment si un jour cela arrive oui
bien sûr quand il y aura des conflits
politique avec un langage mesuré et des
demandes qui soient logiques on pourra
organiser une manifestation
pro proalestine ou proisraélienne G etit
très respecte
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
parce que en disant ça me rassure mais
en disant que les que les les gens qui
manifestent ne peuvent pas manifester
pour la Palestine vous bridez vous
empêchez tous les musulmans modérés de
s'exprimer et dans ces manifestations
c'est pas vrai qu'il y a que des excit
jus B pas vous n'écoutez pas que j'ai
parfaitement écouté laissz les gens dire
on a le droit de soutenir la Palestine
des gens ont le droit de soutenir la
Palestine même aujourd'hui suis pas venu
là pour disputer je suis ven pour dire
quelque chose parce que cyil m'a invité
que j'avais envie de parler de son ce
dont je veux parler avez-vous eu dans
les dernières années vous vu une
manifestation prop palestinienne où on
ne crie pas à mort Israël mort aux Juifs
mais quand on crie çavez vu mais
avez-vous vu une PAL une manifestation
propalestin c'est vous qui êtes un
utopiste non parce que beaucoup sont
noyutter je suis d'accord avec Valérie
mais si vous laissez pas les gens dire
on soutient la Palestine vous allez
cristalliser totalement pas des
manifestations
proalestiniennes ce sont des
manifestations pro Hamas il ne faut pas
les accepter c'est pas vrai bah si com
même il y avait un drapeau iranien sur
les images qu'on voit tout à l'heure
derrière Cyril on a vu un drapeau
iranien et on a vu aussi des messages
qui sont vraiment pas toutes les
personnes qui ont manifesté toutes les
personnes qui ont manifesté sont
proterorisme non non c'est pas ça qu'on
dit on veut dire que ça mal géré mais
moi je te dis je suis moi je suis pas
contre des manifestations just là on
peut AC organ mais on peut pas accepter
que sur la statue de la République il
ait le drapeau iranien bien mais les G
conna m pas les imag g juste veulent
juste apporter un peu de soutien oui
mais faut faire avec le respect de
l'UR pu aller dans les de manif mais
bien évidemment ouais vraiment
oua moi sil y avait une manifestation
logique palestinienne et logique
israëlien je ser aussi avec lui le
problème si vous voulez qu'on est on est
dans l'utopie là la situation est
brûlante on vientir un crime de masse un
un un génocide on vient on vient de
vivre quelque chose que qui est
insupportable qui est inhumain est-ce
qu'il y a des hommes qui peuvent faire
ce qu'on a vu faire est-ce que des
hommes peuvent s'appeler comme ça Primo
Levi a écrit un livre qui s'appelle si
c'est un homme au sortir des camps de
concentration il pourrait écrire le même
livre aujourd'hui donc on n'est pas dans
cette situation on n'est pas dans une
sit une situation d'apaisement où Force
Ouvrière fait une manifestation pour
réclamer une heure de de vacances en
plus ça n'a rien à voir avec ça on est
dans un état de guerre d'un monde qui
veut vivre à sa façon contre un monde de
terroristes merci Ellie d'avoir été avec
nous merci mon Ramous merci Ellie tout
de suite c'est le son de la vine
d'ailleurs sur C8 et lundi on traitera
l'affaire Marwan berini bien entendu
merci à tous